Joy Diaz's daughter caught him smoking
weed in the funniest way possible she
goes dad are we going to go eat
something I go absolutely go change your
hair and get a jacket and I'll wash my
hands and we'll leave well I went
outside to sneak a bong hit and I'm
sitting there with the bong in my hand
and she comes go Dad I'm ready she saw
the [__] guys she saw the [__] after he
was caught red-handed Joey was forced to
sit Mercy down and come clean about one
of his favorite habits I go listen when
I was 133 I was raised this particular
way I knew what drugs were and I knew
the evils of them but one day Mercy I
just couldn't take it and I didn't like
alcohol and my friends were smoking pot
I took that [__] joint I took a hit
off it and I go my world changed M I go
I didn't have anxiety no more it's safe
to assume she would have eventually
figured it out given that there's
literally hundreds of videos of Joey
Diaz smoking on YouTube so the fact that
she actually caught him in person makes
me think